well thank you very much for those moat
but most kind and gracious introduction
you make me sound a heck of a lot better
than I am in real life most people think
I just couldn't get out of school I
guess I'd like to begin by adding my
congratulations to the family faculty
guests friends and of course the
graduating class of 2010 I'd also like
to thank the University the school and
the Dean for offering me this
opportunity to address you today now I'm
sure despite that introduction that they
might be some of you who are saying
yourself what does this guy have to tell
me about engineering well I may have
appeared to have traveled quite away
quite a long way since I last that in
the chairs that you occupied today but
in truth I still use much of what I
learned here in engineering in my work
almost every day that's because much of
the improvement in the health of the
public has been achieved and is still
being achieved through engineering
solutions if you consider the large
improvements in morbidity mortality in
this country over the last 150 years
they were not principally due to new
medicines safer surgery or even vaccines
although I would note that engineers
contributed to all of those also but
rather they were due to the provision of
safe water sanitation cleaner energy
sources better transportation better
housing all very much engineering
solutions as a matter of fact one of the
prime movers behind the organized public
health movement in this country was a
graduate of the Columbia of Columbia
engineering he was an 1899 PhD graduate
from what was then the henry crown
school of mines here at columbia and his
name was George Soper his work on the
typhoid mary epidemic in new york in new
york city in 1907 was the primary
catalyst for the development of a new
discipline called public health which
attempted to combine engineering and
medicine and which eventually led to the
founding of the three first three
schools of Public Health at Harvard
Hopkins and Columbia so I think you can
see that engineering and public health
have a long shared history and are
actually intimately connected in that
both disciplines work to build a better
world in public health we vote we focus
on that better world as being a
healthier world on my own personal
journey from engineering to public
health as the Dean has eluded
I did manage to accumulate a lot of
degrees and one of the corollaries of
having done that as well as being a
faculty member for so many years is that
I have had the chance to hear dozens and
dozens of class day and commencement
speakers over the years and I thought
that this would surely be of assistance
as I prepared to address you today oddly
though thinking back over all those
speakers all that I came to mind was
that they seem to speak too long and
there was nothing in particular like
remember that they said this of course
turned out to be very reassuring to me
because I thought I can do that easily I
can drone on endlessly and say things
nobody will ever recall and I have years
of students behind me who would had
tested that readily but as the day grew
closer I found myself thinking a bit
more ambitiously and keeping in mind
that one of the greatest speeches of all
times Lincoln's Gettysburg Address was
only two and a half minutes long I
decided it's time to break with
tradition I'm actually going to be brief
and try to say something memorable and
I'm sure right I'm sure you'll be
thankful for the former if not the
latter although I warn you despite the
beard I'm no Abe Lincoln so settle in
since this is an institution of higher
learning one of the great institutions
of higher learning I want to say
something about higher education in
particular in general and engineering
education in particular and the
overarching theme that I would like you
to consider with me over the next few
minutes is engineering as a profession
and the engineer as an agent of social
justice something you probably have not
thought of before although maybe you
have so let me start with a quote from
someone who could be brief but memorable
Albert Einstein said the world we have
made as a result of the level of
thinking we have done thus far creates
problems we cannot solve at the same
level of thinking at which we created
them I'm going to repeat that the world
we have made as a result of the level of
thinking we have done thus far creates
problems we cannot solve at the same
level of thinking we have created which
created them you have all spent years
acquiring a level of thinking about
engineering in science that operates on
a sending levels of understanding you
are all well versed in the generation
collection of data the analysis of data
to create information and the synthesis
of information to produce knowledge
but the new level thinking needed
requires more than knowledge although I
might usually be reluctant to quote
somebody like Donald Rumsfeld on the
subject of knowledge and it occurs to me
that many of you may not know even who
Donald Rumsfeld is but there is
something that you're what he once said
he categorized knowledge as the known
knowns that's the things that we know
that we know we have that we have the
question and we know the answer the
known unknowns the things that we know
we don't know we have the question but
we don't yet know the answer and the
unknown unknowns the things that we
don't know that we don't know in fact we
don't even have the question something
to think about and that's where I I
Robbie's mother comes in who's that well
this name I hope may be familiar to you
I I Robbie was actually a Nobel
prize-winning physicist at Columbia he
worked over there and pupae for many
years and when he was asked how come he
was able to do such groundbreaking work
to win the prize as a good Jewish boy he
said it was all due to his mother
mother's pay attention every day after
school he would sit down over milk and
cookies with his mother and talk and the
key thing that she asked him was not
whether he got a good grade on the tests
or if they answered everything correctly
but rather did he ask any good questions
so what's that good question that will
drive us to the requisite new level of
thinking about engineering I think it's
what makes a wise engineer we must
strive for that level of thinking that
transforms the knowledge we have gained
into wisdom after all we say that the
highest degree in higher education is
the PhD the doctor of philosophy from
the Latin to teach and the Greek a love
of wisdom wisdom requires that our
evidence-based knowledge becomes
embedded in a multi-dimensional
ecosystem of understanding with other
levels of thinking including a dimension
of ethics based values such as humanity
humility and honor among others in other
words I think knowledge requires an
ethic to be used wisely now I see some
eyes glazing over this is the point
where those few of you who are still
listening to me will be saying to
yourself I don't care about that ethic
stuff if i'm technically as proficient
as I can be I have done my job and my
answer to that is do you think of
yourself as a technician or
professional engineering is defined in
one dictionary as the application of
science by which matter and energy in
nature are made useful to people I'm
sure you would all agree that you should
be as proficient in applying science to
transform matter and energy but the rest
of that definition is equally important
if not more so mainly in a way that is
useful to people the decision about what
is truly useful is a value judgment
about what is good and bad in other
words it requires incorporation of an
ethic space dimension as well as an
evidence based dimension in your
framework of understanding the linear
dimensional framework of technical thing
at which I'm sure all of you excel must
be embedded in a multi-dimensional
framework in which one of the other
orthogonal axes is ethics you want to
put in engineering terms the technical
engineer stops at the linear thinking
part but the professional engineer
operates in that larger framework we all
talk about an engineering profession and
in fact in every state in the Union you
can earn the legal credential
professional engineer but what does
being a professional mean one thing it
means is that not only have you been
privileged very privileged because you
here at Columbia to acquire specialized
skills and knowledge but also that you
recognize that that privilege comes with
responsibilities one of which is to use
the skill and knowledge wisely in a way
that is useful to people some of the
engineers of a prior generation who
designed and built the gas chambers for
the concentration camps made them
technically and frightening Lee very
efficient but it would be difficult to
say that they use their knowledge wisely
or that they acted professionally the
challenge for this generation of
engineers is to accept your professional
responsibilities and act wisely
tempering your technical prowess with
ethics this is the new level of thinking
that is needed to solve the problems
created as a result of the level of
thinking we have done thus far this old
level of thinking has made a world that
is profoundly technologically efficient
in a way that is equally profoundly
unjust and unsustainable we have become
so technologically proficient
manipulating matter and energy in nature
to create and maintain our oversized
ecological footprint of our western
lifestyle that we have in effect
condemned a significant fraction of this
generation to extreme poverty just as an
example consider that the average
ecological footprint of the typical
American you me and everyone here is
five times that of the world average if
all resources and ecosystem services
were distributed equally around the
globe and it is 15 times that of the
average ecological footprint of a
typical citizen of the third world and
the solution is not merely one of making
a current level of thinking about
technology available to the rest of the
world so that they can pursue our way of
life we have already exceeded their its
carrying capacity with this level of
thinking and it would require at least
four to five planet Earth's to do the
same for the whole world's population
and as I recall planets good planets are
hard to find which would only mean
condemning future generations to global
ecological catastrophe so we need a new
level of thinking that recognizes that
technological efficiency in the service
of the privileged few of this generation
is unwise because it is unjust to the
rest of humanity alive now and yet to be
born it's true that we must all change
our level of thinking but you as
professionals with your specialized
skills and knowledge have a
responsibility to be leaders in this you
should show the way you can show the way
you must show the way living up to your
professional responsibilities is not
just about knowing but about caring
because in the end people will not care
how much you know until they know how
much you care so there's a lot of hard
work ahead of you it's time is running
short as you heard maybe two years maybe
less so you better get started that's
why today is part of a commencement it's
really just a start I do have every
confidence that you will succeed because
you don't only not know what you don't
know you don't know what you can't do
and that's good because you can probably
do just about anything but I also think
the Dean may have failed to mention the
bad news although you will receiving
your diploma soon
you must pass one final exam before you
fully deserve them you didn't know that
hmm the good news is it's a take-home
exam you get too great at yourself and
you have a lifetime to complete it if in
40 or 50 years at the end of your
professional career you can look at
yourself in the mirror and truthfully
say that you've used your knowledge
wisely to build a better world for all
then you will have earned your degree so
go build a better world we're all
counting on your leadership your
professionalism and your wisdom thank
you